[Music]  from ex-con to ex-wife hot felon Jeremy  Meeks his ex Melissa throws in epic  divorce party the blonde beauty marked  the end of her marriage by celebrating  in Sin City  Melissa lived it up at the Crazy Horse  three strip club on Saturday rocking a  sequined black mini dress and giant hoop  earrings after posing for photos with  her girlfriends inside the club the  decor was fully on brand for the  occasion a free at last' banner a  handcuff shaped cake that read yes  ex-con to ex-wife and get this a fan  even presented her with a self-portrait  as for Jeremy who welcomed a baby boy in  May with his new lady love Topshop  heiress Chloe green melissa says she's  on good terms with her ex and added that  they're focused on co-parenting  [Music]  [Applause]  you